I think the most important thing is we
have to maintain fiscal discipline
whether it be in our fiscal deficits
whether it be in terms of focusing in
terms of development in areas which can
generate scarce resources and therefore
back inflation rates and in terms of
integrity in a leadership
oh that that's completely irrelevant
frankly one wouldn't even think of it
it's a mature democracy of 1.1 1 billion
people we've had a tradition of
successful democracy since 46 47 we
applauded around the only governments
democratic governments in the world
which for more than 10 years has
successfully led and managed coalition
governments Alliance governments Britain
is facing it now and they're panicked
whereas we've done it successfully for
10 years three governments and done it
and the job has got done the job of
nation-building the job of nation
leadership in a difficult complex
coalition government has worked what
more majority can you expect from a
democracy
it will make sense because they come
are going up the value chain and as the
international companies are trying to
learn our business models we are
learning their business model properly
faster than they're learning our
business model so cost arbitrage will
always be there because the cost
arbitrage is not determined by two
million engineers in the country who are
working on a job or three million
engineers in a country of work on a job
the cost arbitrage is determined by the
standard of living of over a million
people which is still much much lower
than the rest of the developed world
much much low and when the developed
world escalates even at 3% on salary
levels a year they escalate on a base of
a hundred whereas even if we escalate at
7% a year on a salary there will not 10%
a year on a salary level we escalate not
on a base of 100 but we escalate on a
base of somewhere between 10 and 20 they
just run mathematics and you will find
that even at high inflation rates the
gap continues to be there if not
increase